可能性それほど強くないんですね
なぜならば何でもチャレンジなんですよ
何でもすごいチャレンジなんです
たとえ家庭を平和で平和な家庭作ろうと思っちゃうと
これすっごい努力しないと自動的にもう平和な家庭は作れないんです
豊かになろうと思ったら
必死で頑張らないと戦わないと豊かにはならないんです
じゃあ 知識的な すごい立派な知識人になろうと思ったら
ただボケしたら知識人になりますかね
ならないんです それまた必死になってチャレンジしなきゃ得られないもんなんですよ
それは体力を言おうと思ったっても
健康的になろうとしたっても
美しくなろうとしたっても
何だかんでも存在っていうのはチャレンジなんですよ
ですから そのチャレンジしないで逃げることは仏教では認めない
そういうのをパーラミターとして
パラミットとして覚るために必要な条件
瞑想始まる前にそれはなくちゃいけない
いっぱい徳を積んで 立派な人間として生きていて
それもできると じゃあそれだったら次にこれにチャレンジしようではないかと
ですから この生き方として仏教はもう徹底的に明るい
徹底的にポジティブ みんな間違って取ってるんですよ
仏教の苦の概念 無常の概念
完全に間違ってとっていて
暗い教えだと 無常だからチャレンジするんです
苦だからチャレンジするんです
苦を乗り越えるために
何もチャレンジしないと
そこでもうさらに苦しみが生まれる
そういうことを言ったのは
この難で二十五種類あります
それから身証の説明に入りますけど
身証の説明に入るともう皆様にわかると思いますけど
これ単純なこの道徳論ではないということは見えるかもしれません
じゃあ本題に入りましょう
この浄心証二十五の中に共浄心証という十九あります
ソウガナサーダーナというわけですね
ソウガナサーダーナという証が十九あります
で そこも大事ですから
この一つ一つ説明していきます
ソウガナサーダーナといえば
この共浄心証ですから
良い心には必ずもある心相なんです
だから十九も揃っていないとよくできない
一応十九はセットで揃うと言ってるんです
ということは いい心がわずかでも生まれたら
その心の中に入っている心相の数がすごい多いんです
悪い心の心相の数が少ないんです
十四もいっぺんに生まれないでしょ
悪い心相の場合は 不善心相の場合はいっぺんに一つの心相がほんのわずかなんです
でも善心の場合は十九は確実に入るんです
セットだから それにプラス七つあるでしょ？あの共一切心証
そこをこっちに七つけたらそこは二十六になっちゃうでしょうし
ですから いい心はいつでも強いんです
ものすごくいい心は強いんです
悪い心よりは まあ後でちょっと仏教の道徳論というのはどういうものか説明しますけど
じゃあ一番目はサッダという言葉
サッダは信という言葉の漢字なんですね
まあこちらはサッダの説明は入ってないんですけど
まあこれはアビダンマのあの基本的な説明には入れませんね
上級クラスになっちゃうと入ると思いますけど
あのサッダというのはこの信ですけど
これはこの普通のこの宗教的な信仰という意味でもないんです
それは心の基本的なある状態なんですね
ですから このサッダというのは
この明るい という意味で取ってるみたいですね
この自信という普通の日本の言葉ありますね
この自信があるというというと
あ これ自信がありますよと言う瞬間
思い出してみてください
自信がありますという瞬間
自分がすごく明るいんじゃないですか？その時心は元気でしょ
何か仕事あ これは任せて任せといてくださいと言う瞬間
自分に自信があるんでしょうね
その時 自分が活動的で活発で
もう暗雲はないんですね
それが芯なんです ですから
自信とすごく似ているんです
で どんないろんなもう我々にトラブルやら問題やら日常よくありますし
で たまに我々はたまにでもあ
これはもう任せといてください
もう心配するなと というふうに自分が言える瞬間で
自分がすごい活動的なんですね
その問題にチャレンジする
逃げません なんとかする
それもあれを その心の状態
ですから サッダという言葉を定義する場合は
心のその汚れがなくなるんだと
昔風な例えがあります
例えば 水が汚れていると
もう使い物にならない
それで何か薬を入れると
何か薬を入れたら その汚れが全部沈んで
もうそこに行くんですね
そういう風にこの心の汚れをなくしちゃって
明るくしてくれる働きが信というんです
だから心のモヤモヤ状態はなくしちゃう
どうしようか どうしようかと心配状態は消える
だからこれも最初に必要なんです
これはこちらで説明しているように
仏法僧を徹底的に信じることを信だというふうな意味ではないんです
それは宗教の定義であって
心理学的な定義ではないんです
ただ 人間に行動するために必要な
この基本的な明るさ ですから
この現代我々は信は確信というふうに訳するんです
英語でconfidenceというふうに訳するんです confidence
というふうな言葉で訳するんです confidence
というのは確信という日本語の言葉
ですから信仰でもないんです
で 確信 これは考えた方がいいんです
じゃあ信仰は何ですかと
信仰も信ですけど すべての信仰は信じゃないんです
たまに暗い信仰もあるんですよ
確信はいつでも明るいんです
だから信仰というのは仏教だけではなくて
他の宗教も信仰している人は信仰しているし
宗教ではなくてもいろんな変なものを信仰している人々もいっぱいいるし
だからみんなに信がありますかというと
それはちょっとわからないんです
その人は明るいか 行動的かないかということで
そこら辺考えなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから とにかく信というのは心の汚れをなくす働き
心が汚れていると なかなか行動的じゃない
暗い 活発ではない それが消えちゃって
なんとなく行動的になってしまう
自信がついてしまう 確信が出てくる
その時はそれは信というんです
そこはありとあらゆる理解と
仏教の話は徹底的に理解して理解していくと
また信というものが出てくるんですよ
まあそこはまあ それとこれ
まあちょっとごちゃ混ぜにしちゃうとちょっと難しいんですけど
それも信なんですけど
例えば徹底的に無常の話を勉強して
因果 因果法則をよく勉強して
そうすると真理はお釈迦様おっしゃっていること自体は真理ですよと
自分には確信が生まれる
それには時間かかりますよ
勉強するために 理解するために
その確信がある それも信なんです
で ちょっとした仕事の場合も
あ それ任せてください
という場合も それはある程度で信なんですね
ただ 強弱の差 レベルの差
次元の差 悟り開く時も信は必要なんですけど
かなり高い次元の信は必要なんです
常に人間には信というものがあるんです
確信というものがあるんです
そうでないと生きていられませんだから
ですから 私たちの日常生活の中でも
たまに たまにではなくて
結構みんな成功して生きてるんだから
人生失敗した人っていうのは少ないし
成功している人々の方が数が多いんです
ですから そういう人々はなぜ成功しましたかというと
明るく元気で 明るくて元気で頑張ったんだからなんです
その明るくて元気で頑張ることは
やっぱり信でなければいけません
確信でないと ですから
この そういう信として理解してほしいんです
特別な仏教という宗教の概念ではなくて
人類 生命 一般的などんな生命にも当てはまる普遍的な真理として理解してほしい
動物の世界を見ても かなり成功して生きてる動物は結構明るいんですね
ちゃんと餌を取ったりして
もう子供育てたりする
これよく頑張ってやってる場合は
まあ結構 動物を見てもよく明るくて頑張ってるなと
見えるんです ですから
人間でも生命の成功の道の始まりは信なんです
それは宗教の信仰だと思ったら
まあちょっと理解しにくくなっちゃうんです
[背景音楽]そこぐらいの説明で十分だと思います
心というものは 心が生まれたら明るい
それだけ覚えておいてください
確信  2番目サティ サティは念という漢字で書いてるもので
ヴィパッサナー瞑想ではもうサティで始まりますから
サティからヴィパッサナー瞑想というものも始まります
そうするとどういうことかと
で サティは英語で言えばアウェアネスでしょうし
気づくことであるし で
これはこの言葉で瞑想していると何か言葉の運動をやってますね
そういう言葉の運動とまたちょっと違うんですね
サティというのは サティというのはアウェアネス
気づいていること いわゆる何が起こるか
何が起こっているかという今の瞬間の状況に目覚めていること
それがわからないでしょうに
何が起こっているかさっぱりわからない人はもう暗いし
常にこの自分置かれている状況に目覚めている
気づいている という状態はサティというわけです
ですから 瞑想しなくてもサティがある時は
人はもう明るくて行動的なんです
それも日常生活の中で考えてみてください
我々は結構元気で いろんなことをやっている時はちゃんとサティがあるんだよ
サティのエネルギーがなくなっちゃうと
もう疲れて まあ嫌になっちゃって
もうやめたと やめたくなっちゃうんです
たまに我々はとても忙しくなる時もあるし
もう夜寝る暇もなくて
いろんな仕事をしなくちゃいけない時もあるし
それでも何のことなく元気で全部やっていて
そこでまた疲れて もうダメだ
もうもうもうどうしようもないと思って
自分が疲れてもう嫌になった瞬間で
もう暗くてサティがない
ですから サティっていうのはまた行動の始まりなんです
気づいている瞬間で 人間というのはすごい行動的
そういうことで ヴィパッサナー瞑想をもって最初にもうサティそのものを徹底的に成長しようとすることは
もう大変な瞑想なんです
だからよく私が言う何か超自然的な神秘的な体験得る道ではないんです
人そのものが成長するんだよ
何も超自然的な何かエネルギーなくても
自分に何もできる 何でもできる
いつでも自分には周りの環境には気づいている
自分が どこにいるか 何やってるか
何が周り起こっているかということに気づいているということは
もうちゃんと把握している
その人には特別と力 誰かからなくても自分で行動できるんです
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想の差がそこに見えるんです
どこから隠れて特別な訓練ではなくて
人そのものを育て上げる
そういうことでも ものすごい本当は瞑想の中ですごい強烈な瞑想なんですよ
他の瞑想とごちゃ混ぜにしているんだから
なかなかそのエネルギーはわからないだけで
純粋に仏法僧に仏法僧
仏法僧を信じて お釈迦様の教えをちゃんと信じて
サティ法僧しか何もないよということで始まると
もうかなり大物になるんですよ
二三週間で もう誰にも負けない知恵が生まれてくるんです
だから他のいろんな瞑想やら
他のいろんな教えやら
ヨーロッパのいろんな概念やら
そういういろいろごちゃ混ぜにして
これにいや これがん治るためには
まあこれにいやと話を誰かから聞いたんですけど
そういう風な中途半端な感覚でやっちゃうと
その正しいサティが生まれてこない
正しいサティが生まれてくるとは
自分の自分全部支配することできるんです
自分の体も支配する 自分の心を自分で支配する
周りの環境も自分が支配する
コントロールする 何でもできるようになってしまうんです
そういうことをサティと言うんですね
だからこの何か工夫してサティを育てなくちゃいけない
それに言葉をかけることも一つの方便であって
で またいろいろ方法はあることはあるんです
まあわかりやすく言えば
今の瞬間に気づいていることだから
妄想しないでやることにちゃんと没頭するというんですか
ちゃんと集中して まあそれだけやりますとか
明日のことを考える 何も計画とかいろいろ考える
で 今 今皿洗うことだったら
皿洗うことだけに絞って
徹底的にそれをやっちゃうと
そこからザーッと知恵が湧いてくる
すぐにあるのは机の上を片付けることであるならば
もう全部他のことを忘れて机の上だけ徹底的に片付ける
そうすると その中からものすごくサッと知恵が生まれてくる
次にやるのは もう買い物に行かなくちゃいけないと
そうすると行く道で歩くことだけだから
歩くことだけ徹底的にやると
その中からある知恵が生まれてくる
店に入ったら買い物することだから
そこら辺全部把握して買い物をすると
そこの中から知恵が生まれる
ですから サティがあるならば
常にいつでもいろんな知恵が湧いてくるんです
知恵が湧いてくればくるほど
人間が元気になってしまう
人そのものが成長する
だからサティで生きていていると
何を見ても何か新しい発見があります
だから新しい発見があると
すごい人生っていうのは楽しいんです
ものすごく明るくて楽しいんです
だからこの科学者であろうが
研究者であろうが もう何年も苦労して苦労して頑張っているのは
何か発見するためなんですね
何か発見したら あの苦労は雲水の如く消えてしまうでしょうに
すごい喜びを感じるんです
で サティの人が それは常に感じているんです
何を見ても その中からその人に
そのシステムについて知恵が生まれてきますから
そういうことで サティっていうのは大変大事な機能であって
意味としては今の瞬間に気づいていること
今の瞬間で今の状況 自分置かれているこの現在の状況にちゃんと気づいていること
目覚めていること それまた明るくて活発的で行動的でないとサティではないのです
ですから この仕事を私に任せてくださいと言える場合は
自分が仕事のことをちゃんと把握しているんです
私にこれだったら自信がありますよという場合は
その仕事について自分がちゃんと把握しているんです
だからサティがあるんです
その瞬間です ですから
我々の人生の中で思い出してみてください
自信がある瞬間に 必ずそのサティもあるんです
その時の自分の理解はサティなんです
この仕事には自信があります
任せてください やりますという瞬間に
サティがちゃんとある
その時の心の状況を覚えておいて
それもヴィパッサナー瞑想に使ってみてください
そうするとヴィパッサナー瞑想もすごい明るい仕事に
やらせを言われないことになってしまうんです
それを理解していないんだから
もういやいやおなしに
もう嫌で嫌で瞑想する
それはかわいそうなんですよ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのはものすごく素晴らしいもので
1分でもできなかったら腹が立つほど大事なものなんです
こういうこんなことをやっても瞑想できなくなっちゃったとかね
それぐらいもう明るくて味わいのあるシステムなんですね
そのサティの本当の意味がなかなかもう体験しないんだから
この瞑想自体がちょっともう進めないんですね
だからサティの働きが理解した瞬間でもう進んでしまっちゃうんです
ですから サティを理解するために
我々の過去 今まで生きてきた人生を見ていてください
いろんなことを我々はやってきました
それでいろんなことを成功しました
それで失敗もしました
そこで 今も自分にはこういうこういう仕事だったら自信があるとかね
こういう仕事だったら今もダメですよとかあるんです
そういうのを分けてみると
自分が成功する時 自分に自信がある時はサティがある
その時の心境を育ててください
それはヴィパッサナーなんです
それから いろんな仕事に自信がない時は暗い
仕事を失敗する時もすごく暗い
その時はサティがないんです
サティがうまく機能しなかった
混乱が生まれて 欲が生まれて
ガタガタ出てくる ですから
このサティっていうのはかなり明るいものだと
行動的であるということを理解して
まあ瞑想をもうちょっと話があります
で サッダー・サティ・ヴィリヤッティった
マヒリヨッタット・ザンキ
ヒリとオッタットという 2つがあります
これザンキですか それにはまあ説明するとちょっと問題が生まれるかもしれませんだけど
仏教の説明はすごい簡単なんです
このヒリヨッタットの
ヒリっていうのは恥ずかしいという感じなんですね
その場合は悪いこと いけないことを
するのは恥ずかしがる
逆に言えば いいことをする場合は元気になるという意味でもあるんです
ザンキというのはそういうことで
恥 恐れること 悪いことをするのはもうやらないと
怖いと 自分を控える だから非っていうのは悪いことをするのは恥ずかしがる
おったったっていうのは悪いことをすることを怖がる
それは分かりやすい仏教という宗教の定義なんです
心理学的に定義すると
非っていうのは この自分の成功に至らない
いろんな自分を不幸になる行動をしないことなんですね
そんなことをやっちゃいけないと
と恥ずかしがる 逆にいいことだったら
何も恥ずかしくなく いいことは堂々とするという
まあ結局行動的って意味なんです
これだったらやりませんと
こんな恥ずかしくてやりません
これだったらやりましょうと決めること
でおったくも同じと まあ例えばこの勉強しなくちゃいけない
テレビもあります そこで自分一人で勉強をやめてテレビを見ると
その人は人生は暗くなってダメになっちゃうんです
そこで なんでバカみてえことテレビ見るのは恥ずかしいんじゃないか
自分が学生だから勉強するのはもうかっこいいんじゃないかと思って
堂々と勉強すると非理が機能しているんですね
次にテレビばっかり見ていると
もう自分がもう試験が
なんて言いますか 失敗しても大変なことになるんではないか
それ怖いと 危ないと やっぱり勉強しなくちゃいけないと思う場合がおったったなんです
ですから 人間の成功のために
人間の悪いことから悪いことをやめて
いいことを選べる この選ぶ機能はこちらにあるんです
これではなくて これをしますと決める時が非とおったったって 2つが機能するんです
で セットなんです 例えば
この仕事に自信がありますから任せといてくださいという場合は
明るくて確信がある その仕事をちゃんと把握している
その時はその人もう決まってるんです
この仕事をやりますと
ですから 確信があってサティがありますという瞬間に
ちゃんと非とおったったもついてるんです
非とおったったっていうのは
懺悔と日本語で言いますけど
それは決断なんですね
何をするかというふうな決断をするんです
だから決断弱い人にはこの非りおったったはしっかりしてないんですね
あれもいいし これもいいし
どっちにしようかとかね
テレビも面白いし 勉強もしなくちゃいけないしという状態だったら暗いんです
これ冷房ですか？暖房ですかね
混ぜやすいんですね ただの空気ですよ
窓開けたらすごいうるさいと思いますけど
じゃあ懺悔というのはある程度の決断力みたいな
みたいなもの 決断そのものでもないんです
で その懺悔がある場合は
人はもやもや状態にはいないんです
やってはいけないことはやらないし
やらなくちゃいけないことは確実にやってしまう状態
それがこの一般 この心理学の世界から離れて
仏教の一般道徳論で喋る場合は
我々は違う説明はするんですね
例えば まあ誰か殺生しようと誘惑する場合は
やっぱり殺生するのは良くないし
まあ捕まったら大変危ないしとかね
怖いしと思ってやらない時は
その 2つがきちんと働いてるんですね
で 学生に勉強やめて ちょっとどこかへ行って隠れて酒でも飲もうかと他の学生が誘惑してたところで
やっぱりまだ年も取ってないし
それを良くないしと思って
もし学校の先生にバレたら大変でしょうし
それから親にバレるんではないかと思って
その怖さを感じてやめる場合はおったったで
あれは自分がもうそんなことをやっちゃったら
自分もうもう恥ずかしく恥ずかしいんじゃないかと
他の生徒たちと比べたら
自分がなんかもう仲間外れになるようなことではないかと思って
それは恥ずかしいと思うと非理が働いていく
普通の日常生活の中でそういうふうに見える 2つなんですね
でも 心理学的に言うと
もうすぐ決める こういう行動をしますと
そういうこの行動的な真相2つなんです
次にアローバ・アドーサ
アローバ アローバっていうのは
このローバは貪りですね
貪りがない状態 あ 貪瞋痴の貪
貪り で 不貪というんですね
あ こっちムドンと書いてますけどね
まあムドンでも不貪でもどっちでもあまりまあ問題ないんですけどね
で ローバ 貪りということは
あの よく知ってるんですけど
このローバが 貪りが心に生まれたら
心はすごい暗い 欲が生まれたらすごく暗いんです
行動がなくなっちゃうんです
行動を失っちゃうんです
で 欲が生まれたら みんなこの欲があるんだから頑張ってるではないかとか勘違いしていますけどね
いろんな面白いことがあるんだから頑張ってるんではないかと
金がいっぱい入るんだから
もう一生懸命仕事してるんではないかとかね
でもそこら辺は心っていうのは瞬間瞬間変わるんだから
金が欲しいと思う瞬間にものすごい暗い
何もできないんです やることを何でも失敗するんです
そこで人間っていうのは心が瞬間変わるでしょ
金が欲しくて仕事をするんだけど
一旦仕事に行っちゃったら仕事にぼーっとして
それを面白くやると それ結果として金が後から来るものなんです
いつでもお金が欲しい
お金が欲しいとやる人は何も成功しない
もうあれ 粘りみたいなもので
ある一箇所にも心が定着しちゃうんです
進めないんです ですから
行動的な心 明るい心にはローバがあったらもう明るくない
ですから 明るい心にはローバがない
貪りはない ですから 私たちの人生の中で
いつでも行動的な瞬間で貪りがないんです
貪りがあったらすぐ暗くなって
もう行動がなくなっちゃう
よくも自分の心を見つめると
それは自分でもわかると思いますよ
この欲で心がもう支配してた瞬間で
自分が何もやらない 暗くてただじーっと待ってるだけ
それで あ これは欲しいんだと思って
欲しいんだったらこういうことをしなくちゃいけないんだと思うと
もう悪い心じゃないんです
例えば何かにものすごい欲が生まれた
美味しくてたまらなくなった
その瞬間 漏婆なんです
その時は暗くて暗くて
そこでまたちょっとこの暗さを置いておいて
これ美味しいんだけど
どうやってそれ得られるのかと思ったら道が見えてくる
この方向で行動すれば得られると
その自分にはその道が実行できると見えてくる
そうすると確信が生まれてくる
確信が生まれてくると同時に状況を把握できる
それ先がある そうすると
何がするべきか 何がしてはいけないかと
その決断力も出てくる
それで行動すると 結果として自分求めたものは得られるんです
ですから 何でも得られるためには
獲得 お金であろうが名誉であろうが
この世間のものであろうが
成功したい場合は その道では成功する道はこの道でないとダメなんです
専心でないと何も成功しない
すごい金持ちになりたくて
人が一生懸命もう仕事ばっかりやってると思っても
その人には宗教心何もないんだと
心は汚れたまんまですよと言ったってそんなのはないんです
心は汚れたまんまだったら何もできない
ですから 大金儲かりたいと思っている瞬間はもう暗いんですけど
それでその暗さはちょっと置いておいて
どうやれば自分がこの目的達成するかと理解する時は明るいんです
あ こうすればこうすればいいんだと
じゃあやりましょうと
いう時は明るくて頑張ってるんです
その時もお金のことを考えちゃうと
また暗くなる また怒りが出てくる
その時はまた仕事に邪魔が入っちゃうんです
だからみんなもう誰も仕事はするんだけど
いつでもトラブルは起こるでしょ
うまくいかないとか それはうまくいかないっていうのは
その時は欲がある あるいは怒りがある
どっちかなんです その時は
このずっと動いている心が一旦停止して
逆に違う方向に 堕落する方向に行ってるんです
また堕落する方向からまた止まって成長する方向へ持っていかなくちゃダメなんです
そういうことで 我々の心に漏婆・欲が生まれると
心は反対に後退する 欲が消えたら
まあ専心する方向へ行ってしまっちゃう
その心の状況はアローバと書くんですね
アローバと書くのは漏婆がない
漏婆っていうのは粘りみたいなもので進めない状態
その粘りが消えたと アローバだと思ったんだから
布団だからムドンだから
もう確実に悟っている状態とかそんな話ではないんです
心は瞬間消滅するんだから
漏婆があるとか 次には漏婆がないとか
次には怒りとか 次には他のとことかに
そういう風な状態です
次の言葉はアドーサ アドーサは怒りがないという意味です
愚痴ですか？もうちでもいいです
無心 無心 怒りがない そういう言葉も
このすごい無責任で選んでるわけじゃないんです
このアローバの代わりに違う言葉を入れてもいいんですけど
仏教ではわざわざとこういう風にこの否定形だけ使ってるんです
それはものすごい深い意味があるんです
例えばこの漏婆っていうのは
物事を自分で欲しがること
そちらの反対のエネルギーっていうのは施すことなんですよ
施すことなんですね そういうふうには書かないんです
で 施すといえば まあなんか人間にちょっとこのどこまでかっていうコントロールがあるんです
どこまで施しますかというと
それはもうどこまでもできるわけじゃないんです
もう最終的に今人間自分の命を与えることはできる
それ以上は何もできないでしょう
だから私は施すよ 実行しますと思った人が全部実行すると
自分が命を与えることで終わっちゃうんです
それで全部終わっちゃいますから
それ以上何も成長ないんですね
お金もあげられるし 自分持ってる知恵も知識もあげられるし
体力もあげられる でもキリがあるんですよ
これ以上はできないんだと
リミットがいつでもあるんです
そうすると成長は妨げるんです
でも 心の状態はそういう状態じゃなくて
お釈迦様おっしゃってるのは
漏婆 貪りの心ない状態
貪りない状態っていうのはいくらでも成長できるんです